hey 42 here in 1670 john ray coined the
phrase the early bird catches the worm
before him it is well to be up before
daybreak for such habits contribute to
health wealth and wisdom said Aristotle
lose an hour in the morning and he will
be all day hunting for its proclaimed
Richard Whateley it is drilled into our
heads throughout our entire lives that
it's better for us to get to bed early
and wake up at the crack of dawn in
doing so we can supposedly get more dawn
and live richer happier lives so when do
you like to go to bed thirty percent of
the population are night owls they
prefer to go to bed late and wake up
late sometime in the afternoon
whereas forty percent of people are
morning logs they are more than happy to
wake up at the crack of dawn but go to
bed early and the remaining thirty
percent of people are somewhere in
between but usually have a slight
leaning towards preferring either the
evening or the morning this is referred
to by scientists as your chronotype so
what's your chronotype the issue that
night owls have is they are often
socially shunned they are called lazy
and they mature people often wrongly
assume that a night owls inability to
wake up early is my choice and they
operated for this their entire lives but
the truth is such people may not be able
to help their late rising and forcing
nice house to wake up early can actually
have disastrous health consequences as
far as scientists have observed all
creatures on earth with lifespans more
than a few days are subject to a
circadian rhythm in Latin circa meaning
around and dm4 day it is the natural
24-hour repeating sleep-wake cycle that
determines when we feel drowsy and it's
time for sleep and it also hints to our
bodies when they should awaken from
their slumber controlled by the rather
awesome sounding suprachiasmatic nucleus
a tiny part of your brain inside your
hypothalamus the suprachiasmatic nucleus
is your internal clock the
suprachiasmatic nucleus is excellent and
keeping time without any external
influence in 1962 French geologist
Michele cifra spent two months deep
underground in a cave where not a splash
of light was able to reach him he found
that his circadian rhythm was able to
keep his sleep wake routine accurate to
around 24 hours but it would often
overshoot by up to half an hour this
revealed that our super charismatic
nucleus is great at approximating time
but without a fixed reference it is
unable to maintain it precisely to the
minute we now know that the
suprachiasmatic nucleus synchronizes
itself and thus our circadian rhythm
with the Sun interestingly however if
you were to hypothetically live in a
permanently dark environment with no Sun
such as your mother's basement and
perhaps you do then your circadian
rhythm would sink itself to any other
consistency that happens on a repeating
24-hour cycle such as temperature
fluctuations or remarkably even your
daily morning coffee these time aligning
events are called site gabe's literally
timegiver
and they are how blind people maintain
their circadian rhythms there are two
important chemicals involved in sleep
melatonin and adenosine melatonin
released by the pineal gland
communicates with our super charismatic
nucleus telling it when it's time for
sleepiness to kick in it is released in
large amounts around our typical bedtime
or annoyingly when you really want to
watch just one more episode of that
Netflix series it really slows down
whilst we sleep eventually halting
production all together when it's time
for us to wake up think of adenosine
however like sleep pressure it is
released in increasing quantities
throughout the day and it swells up more
in volume in our bloodstream longer that
we are awake it actually slows down our
neurons which causes us to feel drowsy
after this sleep pressure builds up to
extreme levels we can no longer fight
sleep you know that feeling when you are
at your desk during the early afternoon
and your head suddenly drops into a
micro slumber then your neck snaps it
back up because you would hate to be
fired from yet another job for sleeping
at your desk this is because the levels
of adenosine in your body have caused
your neurons to slow down to such a
level that you can no longer physically
stay awake a power nap is in order
this afternoon drowsiness happens to us
all since adenosine release spiked
during the afternoon and then again just
before bedtime so perhaps the esters are
just meant to be after all although
research has shown at this afternoon
drowsiness only occurs in people who
regularly failed to get sufficient sleep
at nighttime so if you have experienced
this then you need to get more sleep
adenosine and your circadian rhythm are
completely independent but related
systems if you have ever pulled an
all-nighter you will have experienced
adenosine in action and how it just for
control with your circadian rhythm
during the first day adenosine or sleep
pressure builds up in your system as per
normal and by that evening your
circadian rhythm decides that it's time
for you to sleep and you will feel tired
but if you can make it through this
period of extreme drowsiness and low
energy levels until the following
morning then you will experience a
second wind but why adenosine will never
stop being released and broken down
until you actually sleep by morning the
adenosine levels in your body will have
reached extremely high levels but
nonetheless you will have a new rush of
energy during this time because your
circadian rhythm doesn't care that you
haven't actually slept it keeps marching
on relentlessly up and down every 24
hours along with the cycle of the Sun
you're super charismatic nucleus is an
accurate but somewhat blind
timepiece so when morning does calm your
circadian rhythm does its usual wakeup
routine and in
uses your body before rush of energy
that will last you throughout the
morning this overrides the neural
slowdown caused by all that built up
adenosine however as the afternoon draws
in on your second day without sleep your
circadian rhythm starts to wind down
your body as bedtime draws closer yet
again but this time the adenosine levels
in your body have built up to such on a
wholly levels that they are ready to
burst so when these two independent
systems once again sync up with one
another you will experience an almighty
energy crush and sleep is almost
inevitable research on 90,000 DNA
samples collated by 23andme reveal that
our bias towards being a night owl or a
morning lark is roughly 50% due to our
DNA and it can never be altered although
it does usually shift slightly more
towards a morning bias as we grow older
it's believed that this genetical
chronotype is inherited from our parents
it's thought that the reason that the
population is split in their DNA
preferences for earlier or later
bedtimes is that in our hunter-gatherer
days is having this divide played a
crucial and beneficial role it's hardly
surprising that in our prehistoric days
when we lived in tribes and we had rival
tribes and deadly predators stalking the
forests and plains of an evening that
having some members of the tribe awake
at all times was quite handy as long as
Bob and Steve were awake from 12:00 a.m.
until 5:00 a.m. when they've usually
woke up then they could keep an eye out
for Dave and then Dave would continue to
watch after Bob and Steve fell asleep at
5:00 a.m. how nice of Dave evolution
this determines that's hardwiring
varying peaks and troughs of awakeness
and sleepiness for a portion of the
population then it would ensure that
there would always be at least one
person awake in each tribe to keep watch
because these people would feel
naturally inclined to still be awake
while others would and more importantly
they would still be alert
we can shift our circadian rhythm
somewhat by up to an hour each night if
we change our sleeping pattern but we
will always have a natural circadian
template a default time of the day when
we are biologically predetermined to
fall asleep
based on our immutable DNA scientists
have now recently been able to sequence
and observe the unique DNA in each of us
that causes these variations in our
chrono types so being a night owl is in
your DNA and whether or not you are
actually lazy the fact that you may
struggle to wake up early may not be
your fault but is in fact hardwired in
your biology just like an actual al the
brain of a night owl functions best in
the evening when they wake up their
prefrontal cortex the front part of the
brain that is responsible for logic and
decision-making is still offline that's
why sometimes you go to work in your
slippers MRI brain scans of night owls
have revealed that this part of the
brain in particular has a warm up phase
where it will slowly ramp up in life
over the course of the morning and reach
peak efficiency
in the late afternoon or early evening
for some people
morning larks are the complete opposites
their prefrontal cortex is at its peak
adored and it loses effectiveness as the
evening draws in this begs an important
question if 30 percent of the population
are unable to use their brains in the
morning our employers making a mistake
by forcing such people to come into work
at 9:00 a.m. at a time when these people
are unable to work efficiently and they
may make more mistakes in the workplace
furthermore asking these people to wake
up and come to work so early
can be detrimental to their health some
people may belligerently proclaim I'll
sleep when I'm dead but these people
will be dead very soon because over 20
reputable studies have been conducted on
the relationship between sleep and
health overwhelmingly these studies have
found that people who don't get the
required eight hours of sleep per night
died sooner adults older than 45 who
sleep less than six hours per night are
200 percent more likely to have a heart
attack or stroke and at any age evidence
suggests that if you sleep for less than
six hours per night for a period of 14
years then your risk of heart disease
increases by a whopping
500% generally a lack of sleep has been
strongly linked to an increased risk of
cancer heart disease diabetes and
dementia so then it seems that more
flexible work schedules are needed
worldwide that are better tailored to
the sleeping habits of individuals
employers will be rewarded with
employees who work harder smarter more
efficiently and most importantly don't
die so dump quickly if you are a night
owl and you suspect that your inability
to wake up and function early in the
morning is holding you back in life then
I encourage you to change your mind
research conducted it South Hampton
University analyzed the sleeping habits
ie chronotype health and the wealth of
over 1,000 subjects in England
contrary to what every sue saying
business guru has ever told you night
owls were found to be on average
wealthier than morning lakhs those who
went to bed later had a larger mean
income and were more likely to own a car
and the latest study also found that
night owls were slightly more
intelligence than morning blocks
interestingly these results were still
true even when the participants took
intelligence tests again in the morning
instead of the afternoon night hull
still outperformed morning lakhs during
the time of the day when their neural
functionality is supposed to be
suboptimal
it's not all bad news for morning chrono
types however in 2012 psychologists at
the University of Toronto studied over
200 people and found that morning blocks
are happier and generally have a better
mood throughout the day they are also
more agreeable more cooperative and more
conscious
thanks for watching I've recently
launched my first book which I'm
crowdfunding stick a flag in it's a
thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and beyond I am so pleased to
announce that the crowdfunding campaign
has now reached a hundred percent so
it's definitely going to be published
which is amazing but there are still
stretch goals to reach so if you want a
first edition signed copy then head on
over to unbound the links in the
description watch the launch video if
you haven't already unpledged today
thank you